- Des pluies torrentielles,
des glissements de terrain
et des champèèèèrement
inondés; le sud de
la Colombie-Britannique est
frappé de plein fouet par
des ins s s s s dévastatrices.
À moins de 100 km de là,
la ville de Merritt,
au coeur d'une région ravagée
par les feux de forêt cet été,
est maintes s s s s l'eau.
Un ordre d'évacuation a été
émis pour tous les résidents,
et plus de 7000 personnesdoivenr
un toit temporaire.
Des centres ont été ouverts
à Kelowna et Kamloops pour
rex x x x x x qui ne peuvent pas
se rendre chez des proches.
Sur les routes, la situation
est chaotique. À la mi-journée,
le Grand Vancoêêêêêême
coupé du reste du pays par
la route. De nombreux axes
routiers de la province
ont été fermés à la circulation,
avec des centaines
d'automobilistes pris au piège.
Notamment à Agassiz,
dans la vallée du Fraser.
Ce cocktail météo est
un événement exceptionnel et
extrême. Les pires inondations
et glissements de terrain
écécécécécécécennies.
ARMEL CASTELLAN, météorologue
Environnement Canada
- C'esecececececececevoir
le mois de novembre en entier
dans 24-36 heures. C'est-à-dire,
c'est 30 fois plus copieux
qu'on devrait l'avoir.EtEtEtEtE,
ça déboussole beaucoup.
- Et le retour au calme
n'est pas pour tout de suite.
Après ces intempéries,
le vent, avec le risque de
chutes d'arbres
de courant, alors que déjà,
des dizaines de milliers
de foyers ont été privés
d'électricité au cours
de la journé